Das gab es wirklich noch nie.
Die japanische Regierung hat einem Forschungsteam
aus Tokio jetzt die Erlaubnis gegeben, ein
Mischwesen aus Mensch und Tier zu züchten.
Dazu sollen menschliche Stammzellen in Tier-Embryonen
eingesetzt werden.
Doch nicht nur das: Diese Mensch-Tier-Chimären
dürfen dann erstmalig quasi bis zur Geburt
heranreifen.
Die Fachleute wollen somit langfristig Ersatzorgane
aus “vermenschlichten” Tieren erzeugen.
Tiere als Ersatzteillager oder Organ-Fabriken
also?”
Kritiker sprechen von einem “ethischen Megaverstoß”.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos, abonniert den Kanal,
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts - herzlich willkommen!
Und vielen Dank für Euren super spannenden
Themenvorschlag, der über die Telegram-Community
kam!
Den Link dazu gibt es in der Videobeschreibung!
Das, was die japanische Regierung jetzt nun
genehmigt und finanziert, ist wirklich einmalig.
Konkret geht es um ein Experiment des Forschers
Hiromitsu Nakauchi, der Mischwesen aus Tier
und Mensch bis zur Geburt heranreifen lassen
möchte.
Langfristig gesehen könnten so Schweine erzeugt
werden, die als “Organspender” für menschliche
Patienten und Patientinnen dienen und somit
dem weltweiten Organmangel entgegenwirken
und vor allem viel mehr Lebensrettende Organe
bereithalten würden.
Auch in anderen Ländern wie den USA wurden
bereits Hybrid-Embryos aus Mensch und Tier
gezüchtet.
Auch in Deutschland ist die Forschung und
Züchtung mit Chimären erlaubt - das Gebären
dieser Mischwesen aber ausdrücklich nicht!
Und so haben Forschungsteams weltweit solche
gezüchteten Mischwesen immer frühzeitig
getötet.
Doch das ist diesmal anders.
Hiromitsu Nakauchi von der University of Tokyo
möchte nicht nur menschliche Zellen in Tier-Embryonen
schleusen.
Er möchte sie auch bis zur Geburt heranwachsen
lassen.
Eine Änderung des japanischen Gesetzes aus
dem März diesen Jahres macht das möglich.
Das japanische Wissenschaftsministerium hatte
damals Einschränkungen aufgehoben, die sich
auf das Einsetzen menschlicher Stammzellen
in Tiere beziehen.
Diese neuen Regeln erlauben es Forschungsteams
in Japan, Tiere zu züchten, die quasi menschliche
Organe ausbilden.
Nakauchis Team ist also das erste, dass nicht
nur Mensch-Tier-Chimären erzeugt, sondern
diese quasi bis zur Geburt heranwachsen lässt.
Der japanische Forscher will diese Experimente
schrittweise durchzuziehen.
In einem ersten Schritt sollen menschliche
Zellen in Ratten- und Mäuse-Embryonen eingesetzt
werden.14,5 Tage sollen die Embryonen im Körper
des Muttertieres heranwachsen.
Dann sind sie schon relativ weit entwickelt
- gewöhnlich tragen Mäuse ihrer Jungtiere
etwa 20 Tage lang.
Ähnlich bei den Ratten: Hier sollen die Mischwesen-Embryonen
15,5 Tage im Muttertier heranwachsen.
Zum Vergleich: 23 Tage beträgt die gewöhnliche
Tragedauer der Ratten.
Auch hier sind die Embryonen also schon relativ
weit in ihrer Entwicklung.
Dann sollen nach dem Plan von Nakauchi auch
größere Tiere herhalten, beispielsweise
Schweine.
Auch hier sollen menschliche Zellen in Schweine-Embryonen
eingesetzt werden, die dann 70 Tage in einer
Sau heranwachsen.
Für dieses Experiment fehlt dem japanische
Forscher allerdings noch eine finale Genehmigung.
Auf Zell-Ebene soll das Ganze so ablaufen:
Den Nager-Embryos werden sogenannte “induzierte
pluripotente Stammzellen” (iPS-Zellen) eingepflanzt.
Diese entstehen, indem ausgereifte Körperzellen
eines erwachsenen Menschen auf einen sehr
frühen, embryonalen Zustand zurück programmiert
werden.
Die Biochemie macht es möglich.
So können Hautzellen die Eigenschaften von
Embryozellen entwickeln, aus denen sich dann
wiederum quasi jeder Zelltyp des menschlichen
Körpers entwickeln kann.
Genetisch gesehen sind solche iPS-Zellen also
identisch mit den ursprünglichen Hautzellen
und das bringt einen entscheidenen Pluspunkt
mit sich: Gewebe, das daraus gezüchtet wird,
würde nach einer Transplantation nicht vom
Immunsystem des Zellspenders abgestoßen werden!
Was hinzu kommt: Kein Embryo muss sterben,
um solche iPS-Zellen zu gewinnen.
In den Experimenten des japanischen Forschungsteams
werden die Nager-Embryos genetisch verändert
und zwar so, dass ihnen eine eigene Bauchspeicheldrüse
fehlt.
So erhoffen sich die Fachleute, dass die Föten
aus den menschlichen induzierten pluripotenten
Stammzellen eine Bauchspeicheldrüse entwickeln.
Aber auch an anderen Stellen im Körper dieser
Mischwesen aus Tier und Mensch könnten sich
menschliche Stammzellen verbreiten.
Dies könnte das Experiment dann auch zeigen,
so heißt es vom japanischen Wissenschaftsministerium.
Ein ähnliches Experiment hatte das Team um
Nakauchi schon vor zwei Jahren (2017) durchgezogen:
Damals hatten die Wissenschaftlerinnen und
Wissenschaftler iPS-Zellen von Mäusen in
Ratten-Embryos eingepflanzt, die durch eine
genetische Manipulation ebenfalls nicht in
der Lage waren, eine eigene Bauchspeicheldrüse
zu entwickeln.
Das Experiment wurde als erfolgversprechend
gefeiert, denn die Ratten hatten tatsächlich
Bauchspeicheldrüsen entwickelt, die aus Mäusezellen
bestanden.
Und nicht nur das: Die so gezüchteten Organe
wurden dann in Mäuse eingesetzt, die an Diabetes
erkrankt waren.
Die Tiere waren dadurch tatsächlich in der
Lage, ihren Blutzuckerspiegel wieder zu regulieren.
Das Ersatzorgan hatte die Tiere wieder gesund
gemacht.
Wir sind allerdings noch lange davon entfernt,
Organspenden aus Tieren zu gewinnen.
Denn das, was Nakauchi macht, ist reine Grundlagenforschung.
Mäuse und Ratten sind evolutionär weit vom
Menschen entfernt und so sind die menschlichen
Zellen gar nicht in der Lage, lange in den
fremden Körpern zu überleben.
Zudem sind die Tiere viel zu klein, um in
ihnen echte Menschen-Organe zu züchten.
Ähnlich bei Schweinen: Auch hier besteht
eine große Hürde dieser Technik darin, dass
Mensch und Schwein evolutionstechnisch gesehen
relativ weit voneinander entfernt sind.
Wahrscheinlich werden sogar noch Jahrzehnte
vergehen bis Patienten, die vergeblich auf
ein Organ warten, mit dieser Technik geholfen
werden kann.
Wenn überhaupt!
Und das ist auch das, was Skeptiker an dieser
ganzen Sache so hart kritisieren.
Es sind nicht wenige Fachleute, die daran
zweifeln, ob diese Technik überhaupt jemals
funktionieren wird.
Vorzuziehen seien andere wissenschaftliche
Ansätze, mit denen menschliche Organe für
Transplantationen bereitgestellt werden könnten..
Beispielsweise beschäftigen sich andere Wissenschaftlerinnen
und Wissenschaftler damit, Organe von Tieren
so umzugestalten, dass sie dann auch Menschen
eingesetzt werden könnten.
Es gibt zudem auch Befürchtungen, dass sich
solche iPS-Zellen so in den Tieren einnisten,
dass sie sich im schlimmsten Fall zu Ei- und
Samenzellen entwickeln.
Oder aber, dass sie die kognitiven Eigenschaften
von den Tieren verändern.
Dazu der Molekularbiologe Jens Reich aus Berlin:
“Es ist sehr heikel, solche Versuche zu
machen.
Die Gefahr dabei ist, dass man ja sehr potente
menschliche Stammzellen in einen tierischen
Embryo hineingibt und man dann nicht mehr
verhindern kann, dass die etwas machen, was
nicht mehr kontrollierbar ist.
Zum Beispiel, dass sie in dem Versuchstier
Hirnzellen (...)bilden."
Und auch andere Dinge können in den anstehenden
Experimenten noch schief gehen.
Beispielsweise, dass sich Krebszellen entwickeln
und dass die menschlichen Zellen zugrunde
gehen.
Auch der SPD-Gesundheitsexperte Karl Lauterbach
gehört zu den Kritikern.
In einem Spiegel-Interview sprach er von einem
“ethischen Mega-Verstoß”.
Seiner Ansicht nach sind die Experimente nicht
tragbar: Mit der Züchtung von Mensch-Tier-Mischwesen
wird eine Grenze überschritten, die wir als
Menschen nicht überschreiten dürfen”.
Der Deutsche Ethikrat hat 2011 eine Stellungnahme
zu diesem Thema veröffentlicht, die bis heutzutage
gilt.
Ethisch vertretbar sind Experimente demnach,
wenn die Grenze zwischen Mensch und Tier klar
erkennbar bleibt und sowohl das Tierschutz-
als auch das Embryonenschutzgesetz streng
eingehalten wird.
Zudem muss auch der Nutzen für den Menschen
groß sein.
Somit befürwortet der Deutsche Ethikrat also
Tierexperimente mit “vermenschlichten”
Tieren, die dazu dienen, Organe in Tiere zu
züchten und diese dann auf den Menschen zu
übertragen.
Dazu der Sozialethiker Peter Dabrock; der
Vorsitzende des Deutschen Ethikrates (in einem
Interview mit dem Nachrichtendienst epd):
“Man denkt vielleicht an Pegasus, Sphinx,
Kentauren oder irgendwelche Horror-Monster
aus Hollywood-Trash-Filmen”.
Dem sei nicht so.
Hinter den Experimenten stünde ein hohes
Ziel.
In der Medizinforschung geht es übrigens
schon seit Jahren um die Erzeugung von Chimären.
In Deutschland konzentrieren sich Forschungsteams
vor allem auf die gentechnische Veränderung
der Tiere durch die Genschere namens “Crispr-Cas9”.
Hierbei werden Oberflächenmoleküle der Tierorgane
so verändert, dass sie menschlichem Gewebe
ähneln.
So erhofft man sich, dass nach der Transplantation
keine Abstoßungsreaktionen stattfinden.
Wir spielen Gott: Gentechnik mit CRISPR-Cas9
Hier erkläre ich genau, was es mit der Genschere
auf sich hat.
Also anklicken, anschauen und an alle nicht
Abonnenten, spätestens jetzt Clixoom Science
& Fiction abonnieren.
Bis dann, bleibt dran!